hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime operor and anime is full
of diabolical villains who just seem to
stick with you because of how cruel and
ruthless they are there are a ton of
memorable top tier villains from
griffith and johann liebert to bone
druid and castor from fade zero but i
never hear upper moon 2 doma being
mentioned in that conversation and he
really should be now i realize that
demonstra is a newer series and at the
full extent of doma's psychotic nature
has only been revealed in the manga as
of the making of this video but the more
i think about it the more i feel that
doma really is one of the most insane
diabolical and brutally evil villains in
the history of anime and manga
this man is the third strongest demon in
the world he is a full-time cult leader
and he is apparently in love with one of
the hashira and that's just scratching
the surface so let's get into it if you
guys enjoy our demonstrator content and
you want us to keep it going you know
what to do just leave a quick like and
comment it only takes a second but it
helps with that youtube algorithm and of
course if you don't want to miss more
demon slayer videos in the future don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications
now a quick shout out to our partner
itaikuji itaikuji is an online retailer
in japan that makes anime merch that is
normally exclusive to japan available to
fans all over the world they have a huge
selection of awesome anime merch
straight from japan including an entire
section on demon slayer they've got the
best demon slayer figurines i've ever
seen available for pre-order right now
including tanjiro rengoku tengenakaza
and more check them out link in the
description and because we're partnered
with them you can now use coupon code
anime opera 500 for an instant discount
just register an account for free it's
really quick and you'll be able to use
the coupon when you use the coupon code
you are not only getting awesome merch
but directly supporting this channel so
check it out link in the description
finally this video will of course
contain demonstra manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned we first meet dolma in the
climax of the entertainment district arc
during yutaro's flashback to when he
became a demon this was over a hundred
years ago and back then doma held the
rank of upper moon 6. he approaches
gyotaro and his sister as they are dying
on the ground and he offers them the
opportunity to become demons our very
first visual of dolma is that of a
smiling bright-eyed young man who just
happens to be holding a woman's body
parts and has blood flowing from his
mouth that one image alone is enough to
convey so so much about this character
and yet this is nothing compared to what
we learned about him as the story
continues his first appearance in the
present time is chapter 98 of the manga
during the meeting of the upper demon
moons called by muzon following yutaru's
death gyutaro is the first upper moon to
be defeated in 113 years and this
infuriates muzon he wants his upper
demon moons to regroup and redouble
their efforts to achieve his ultimate
goals which are destroying the demon
slayers and obtaining a way to conquer
the sun the situation is extremely tense
for everyone and yet doma is grinning
from ear to ear he casually places his
hand on aka's shoulder and starts
talking about how worried he was about
everyone because they are all his
precious comrades doma is saying this
because when they were all summoned to
the infinity castle they knew that one
of the upper moons was likely killed but
they didn't know which one you really
get the feeling that dolma is not being
completely sincere here and that his
behavior in general is just somehow off
doma tells gyoko that he placed a
woman's freshly severed head into a vase
that gyoko had given him and doma is now
using that vase to decorate his room
yeah that is the kind of person that
doma is and the creepiest thing here is
that dolma isn't trying to be like edgy
or provocative he genuinely doesn't
think that there is anything wrong with
his actions and he talks about his new
quote-unquote decoration as casually as
someone would talk about a new lamp or
carpet it's clear from the get-go that
akaza despises doma and even punches
doma's jaw off because the other demon
was touching his shoulder when muzon
arrives and reveals that gyutaro has
died doma apologizes because he had been
the one that brought yutaro into the
demon ranks he even offers to gouge out
one of his eyes as punishment but muzan
says that there's no need however even
as doma is apparently being apologetic
and offering to punish himself he is
still grinning from ear to ear his
mannerisms and expressions don't seem to
match his words and that is a constant
creepy theme with doma as muzon
dispatches gyoko and huntengu on a
mission to the swordsmith village doma
eagerly screams out that he wants to go
too and then akaza decides to smash half
of his head off because he was speaking
out of turn to lord muzon kokushibo the
strongest demon moon then admonishes
akasa for going too far by striking
someone above his own rank but a newly
regenerated doma smiles again and says
that he doesn't even mind akaza's
attacks according to doma akasa is just
upset that despite becoming a demon
before doma doma is already stronger
than him and that is why akaza has a
lower rank throughout this whole meeting
doma is acting almost like he wants to
be friends with the other upper moons
even though that is clearly not the type
of relationship that they have with each
other but again doma's lighthearted
behavior seems somehow insincere it's
like an act but an act that he himself
is trying to believe before leaving the
upper moon meeting after his request to
join the mission was rejected doma seems
like he's trying to ask the biwa player
nakime out on a date but she instantly
declines and sends him back to his home
and that is when we find out what doma
does in his spare time it turns out that
doma is the leader of a cult called the
paradise faith doma was born with
remarkable rainbow-colored eyes and
pristine white hair which made people
start to worship him as some sort of
supernatural being his own parents
convinced themselves that doma could
hear the voices of gods and so they
created the paradise faith religion
around him doma never heard the voices
of gods and he found it ridiculous that
fully grown adults would believe this
stuff and that they would worship him a
clueless child he thought all those
people were crazy because he himself
didn't even believe in paradise he
believed that it was all just fairy
tales and he thought that the people who
believed them were so dumb that it
actually made him cry but doma played
along because he wanted to use his
position to help all these pitiful
people and to make them happy i mean
that doesn't sound so bad right sure he
didn't believe in the cult's teachings
but he was at least trying to use his
position to help people right
right well just wait until you find out
how exactly doma thinks he is quote
unquote helping people while doma was
still fairly young his mother found out
that his father was cheating on her with
female followers of the cult she then
proceeded to stab him to death before
taking her own life but doma didn't feel
shocked or sad or lonely after this
happened his first thought was that his
mother shouldn't have made such a mess
in the room and that someone now has to
clean all that blood human emotions
meant nothing to him even before he
became a demon and he saw them all as
akin to pointless dreams in short doma
was always a complete sociopath and this
was only exacerbated further once doma
met muzon and became a demon at the age
of 20. after becoming a demon doma
became immortal and since he never
believed in paradise or an afterlife of
any kind doma developed the warped
belief that because everyone fears death
they can just live forever through him
after he devours them and because his
victims are no longer afraid of anything
or suffering in any way after he eats
them doma believes that he is actually
saving them by devouring them this is
truly one of the most warped and
sadistic philosophies that i have ever
come across and this is one of the major
reasons why i think doma deserves to be
mentioned among the most brutal and evil
villains in the history of anime and
manga for generation after generation
dolma used his cult to attract female
followers whom he would then manipulate
and devour and not only would he do it
without any empathy or remorse but he
actually felt good about himself because
he genuinely believed that he was
offering nothing short of salvation to
these women some 15 years before the
beginning of the story inosuke's own
mother sadly fell victim to doma
inosuke's mother was only 17 or 18 years
old when she decided to escape from her
abusive husband who would beat her up
every day she had no family and no one
to turn to so she sought help and
shelter from the paradise faith for her
and her baby she had been beaten so
badly that she had gone blind in one eye
and her entire face was swollen but once
she healed up doma thought that she was
quite beautiful her name was kotoha and
in fact inosuke looks a lot like her
apparently doma wasn't planning on
devouring inosuke's mother because he
enjoyed having her by his side but
kotoha was observant and she realized
that doma was secretly devouring his
female followers kotoha couldn't just
stand by and watch this happen so she
confronted doma cursed him and tried to
flee his temple doma didn't want the
truth to get out so he cornered kotoha
in the woods and killed her when his
mother was killed babinosuke fell from a
cliff and into a body of water doma
assumed that the baby had died but
instead the baby survived and was raised
in the wilderness by wild boars after
killing kotoha doma devoured her whole
bones and all and as you might expect he
didn't regret it at all because he is
such a sick psychopath according to doma
kotoha's life was miserable and
meaningless but because he devoured her
she could now live forever inside of him
doma would eventually come face to face
with inosuke during the infinity castle
arc and he would shamelessly gloat about
what he did to his mother right in front
of him over a decade after the death of
kotoha and only about four years before
the present time doma faced kanai kotro
the former flower hashira in battle
kanai was the older sister of
shinobukocho and she was fatally wounded
during that battle with doma although
doma was unable to finish her off and
devour her because the sun was coming
out and he had to flee when he comes
face to face with shinobu during the
infinity castle arc doma says that he
remembers kanae and that she was kind
and cute he then says that he regrets
that he couldn't finish devouring her
because the sun came up and so he had to
run away now shinobu is determined to
avenge her sister and she has been
planning for this moment for years she
then engages dolma in a bitter battle to
the death and despite the fact that she
puts up an incredibly valiant effort
ultimately doma manages to seriously
injure shinobu just as it seems that
shinobu has been defeated she sees a
vision of her sister kanai even though
in the past kana had told her sister to
just quit being a demonstrator so she
can live a normal life this time kana
tells shinobu to stand up she tells her
that now that she's already gone this
far she has to defeat this demon so
shinobu forces herself to stand up
despite having multiple injuries and she
attacks domain again using her
unbelievable speed shinobu is so fast
that even an upper moon like doma cannot
anticipate her next move she even
manages to pierce doma right through the
neck with her poison laced sword shinobu
isn't strong enough to actually take off
an upper moon's head but she hopes that
poisoning him in such a vital spot will
be enough to take him out doma still
appears to be unaffected by her poison
consistent with his previous psychotic
behavior doma grabs shinobu as if he's
hugging her tears flow down his face as
he tells shinobu how admirable it is for
her to keep fighting so bravely despite
the fact that her situation is utterly
hopeless she's so weak and yet she's
trying so hard and doma thinks that this
is just adorable doma proclaims that
because shinobu has impressed him so
much he now considers her worthy of
being devoured by him so the two of them
can be together forever when doma asks
shinobu if she has any last words she
just tells him to go to hell this this
was such an emotional and heartbreaking
moment i remember while reading this
part of the manga three different things
were going through my mind at the same
time first seeing shinobu lose her life
like this was heart-wrenching at the
same time i also felt such respect for
her for standing her ground and fighting
so bravely until the very end finally i
couldn't help but think what a creepy
and terrifying villain doma is like this
man is genuinely scary he is a terrible
terrible person but that also makes him
a pretty great and memorable villain as
a helpless canal watches in utter shock
doma begins absorbing shinobu into his
own demon body and by the way kanao with
an o is shinobu's apprentice kana a with
an e is shinobu's sister kanao tries to
attack doma and save shinabo using the
fourth form of flower breathing but doma
is too fast he even smiles and begins to
gloat about how fine feasts seem to be
coming to him one after the other just
inhuman levels of evil but kano then
says something very important she calls
out doma for what he is right to his
face he is nothing but a blatant
sociopath who is completely incapable of
feeling normal human emotions he
pretends to show emotions because he has
learned over time what the socially
appropriate response is in a given
situation
but deep inside he feels nothing he is
nothing but an empty shell that is why
in the end kanai had actually felt sorry
for him before she died and when i saw
kanawha say this it honestly explained
so much about doma it explained why his
behavior and expressions just don't seem
to fit with the situation and why he
always seems like he's putting on an act
even if he himself has convinced himself
that the act is real doma is a truly
demented sociopath who simply cannot
comprehend the feelings of other people
he doesn't have any sympathy for or
connection with other people and so he
is always just playing a role he is
acting the way that he thinks he is
supposed to act when in truth he himself
is nothing but an empty rotting shell
kano's words must ring true here because
dolma is clearly displeased by what she
has said and the two of them engage in a
fierce battle just as doma manages to
take her sword and just as it looks like
it's finally game over for kano our boy
inosuke shows up and joins the fight a
short but intense showdown ensues
between kano and inosuke and doma and
then unexpectedly shinobu returns to
center stage for one final act it turns
out that shinobu knew ahead of time that
in order to defeat upper moon 2 doma the
man who killed her sister she would have
to sacrifice her own life and so she
always intended to do exactly that she
knew that doma was a glutton who loved
devouring women in particular and she
knew that he wouldn't be able to resist
devouring a female hashida with a strong
body so shinobu began ingesting wisteria
flower poison little by little for over
a year so that she would slowly build a
resistance to it and so that she could
have a lot of it circulating through her
body when doma eventually consumed her
with her sword alone shinobu was able to
only deliver a small amount of poison
into doma's body and it was never enough
to do anything to him but once he
consumed her he also consumed 70 times
the lethal amount of wisteria poison as
doma is fighting kano and inosuke all
that poison finally kicks in his body
begins to literally break down his very
bones begin to melt and even with his
demonic regeneration he cannot undo the
effects of such an immense amount of
poison doma desperately tries to keep
himself together but kano and inosuke
work as a team to cut off his head and
so upper moon to doma is finally
defeated but even death is not the end
to doma's terrifying creepiness doma
suddenly finds himself face to face with
shinobu once again presumably somewhere
between this life and the next shinobu
gets to see the outcome of her sacrifice
and doma must accept his death at her
hands and while you might expect doma to
be angry or afraid or shocked he is none
of those things instead true to his
madness until the very end doma tells
shinobu that he finally understands what
love is because after everything that
they just went through together doma
knows that he truly loves her doma then
asks shinobu if she would accompany him
to hell and shinobu smiles and says
after you you worthless bastard yeah so
now you know why i find doma to be such
a terrifyingly creepy villain his way of
thinking and acting is just so different
from a normal human his method of
helping people is so warped his
understanding of love is so twisted and
the way that he smiles while saying and
doing the most grotesque things
imaginable is just so uncanny in terms
of his worldview and mental state domain
is by far the scariest out of all the
villains and demon slayers in my
personal opinion and that includes muza
i mean sure all demons do terrible
things but their motivations are usually
simple to understand they want
immortality or they want power or they
just like to fight and so on but doma he
is something else a cult leader who
saves his followers by devouring them a
sociopath whose entire life is an act
but an act that he himself has started
to believe and the man whom shinobu has
dedicated her life to destroying and yet
that very act of destroying him has made
doma fall in love with her
wow it is hard to find the words to
properly describe a man as dark and
twisted as dolma all i can say is well
done to gotoge the author of demonslayer
for creating such a captivating and
memorable villain okay now guys let me
know who is your favorite villain and
demonstrator and do you agree with my
analysis of doma leave a comment down
below i always love hearing from you if
you're looking for a video to watch next
we have an entire video on doma's powers
and how strong he really is link in the
description don't forget to check out
itaikuji and use the promo code anime
opera 500 link down below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more demonstrator content here on
the channel very soon don't forget to
leave that like it only takes a second
but it really helps and if you're new to
anime pro or maybe you've been watching
our stuff but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you might
think it's not a big deal but yeah one
person subscribing actually helps a lot
on youtube you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at
animeopror as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboy